you know they're robbing from the rich
to give to the poor too but also to give
to themselves
i mean they're they are have become
quite a bit like the uh
like the robin hood thing and a number
of the especially the new recruits have
joined them are not the original knights
who set forward knights and men at arms
who stepped forward with them
but are people who were outlaws who
committed some crime or other and were
were outlawed
and had to take to the woods to avoid
from being hung and all that and these
people have gravitated to the
brotherhood
um to fill out their their numbers
and they're essentially guerrilla
fighters at this point they they
couldn't stand up in a
open battle against any of tywin
lannister's uh
armies but they melt away into the woods
and then they can't be found and
and uh you know no one knows who they
are and
they're led by the lightning lord beric
dondarrion you know the house
dondarrion's uh
sigil is a forked lightning bolt on a
black field so
so they call him the lightning lord
because of his heraldry and
because he appears like lightning he
appears from nowhere and then he's gone
and he can't be killed you kill him and
he's back again the next week so
obviously this draws more and more
people to him you have a you have a
supernatural leader who can't be killed
and
uh who is creating all this trouble for
the lannisters
king robert still lived and lord eddard
stark had just survived an ambush by
jaime lannister in king's landing
we were the king's men charged by the
king's hand to bring the king's justice
to the false knight
gregor clegane who was raping and
murdering the king's subjects in the
riverlands
to be honest i cared more about the
king's cellars but i joined lord barrack
for the adventure
and maybe a grateful milkmaid or two
segregate isn't called the mountain
because of his subtlety
yet he took us by surprise at the
mummer's ford he'd hidden his men
on both banks and as we crossed he fell
upon us from the front
and rear i saw a single blow from his
sword take a man's arm
off and kill the horse beneath him
many of us though were simply written
down and drowned
the survivors spotted my damn red cloak
and rallied around me
and we cut our way free a hundred men
we'd been that morning
by dark only 40 were left and lord beric
looked to make us 39 before morning
i drew a foot of lance from his chest
and poured boiling wine into the hole
that left
but i knew there was no hope when his
light failed i shut his eyes
placed my hands on his cold chest and
mumbled a half-remembered blessing over
his body
because he was my commander and my
friend
and i didn't know what else to do then
i felt his heart thud beneath his breast
his body shuddered as the fire of life
rekindled inside it
i used to joke that i became a red
priest because the robes hit the wine
stains
but the wine itself had an unbelieving
heart
when beric's eyes opened so did mine
i fell to my knees and praised the one
true god
and begged forgiveness for my ways i
don't know if the lord heard me but when
dawn came beric was still alive
and stronger than he'd been
he told us that our war hadn't ended at
the moment's forward but begun
and that every fallen brother would be
avenged
we were so few though that all we could
do was harry the lannister's rear
luckily all they could do was kill beric
a lannister mace shattered his helm and
skull
a noose snapped his neck after he
surrendered himself to save a beekeeper
and his wife
the mountain's dirt pierced his eye
through his visor
after each time i stood over his corpse
and prayed to the lord
and the lord brought him back
then we heard that robert was dead and
lord eddard too
we'd been sent by the king's hand to
deal with outlaws but now
we were the outlaws and lord tywin was
the hand of the king
some wanted a yield but beric wouldn't
hear of it we were still king's men he
said
and these were the king's people the
lions were savaging
if we could not fight for robert we
would fight for them
until every man of us was dead
we'd lost the king's banner at the
mummer's ford but then the countryside
was awash with sigils and armies anyway
we became the brotherhood without
banners beric led us in battle
and i led us in prayer and the lord of
light
led us in everything when the heralds
proclaimed the end of the war of the
five kings none of us thought of
yielding
our war wasn't over the generals had
gone home but the soldiers stayed
either they had no homes to return to or
they'd gotten a taste for other peoples
the brotherhood was the people's only
defense
we became the brothers of murdered
siblings
husbands of murdered wives and fathers
of murdered children led
by a murdered man once we sought to
bring the king's justice to the realm
now we bring the lords or at least we
try